[Music] The
name is Aamir
111 They refuse in our house, so whenever I
do work, I come home and pay the money,
this is more expensive than this 120 Reply It's just
that this ₹ 100 is clocked off that
today for three days  I earned ₹ 1000, do it or do it
[music]
I know studies are more important but the
circumstances of my family were such that
we started working,
I would work in the bus and brother
would work.  If there is then definitely do it so that those who are
reading will read it inshallah, what has
happened is that there is a
ghost on this work
[music]
that it will not even be counted, is it that
everyone is connected to the
whole of India when Bengal  Gets
respect everywhere from Bihar to Mumbai Do Do Do Do [
Music]
Do Do [
That A
[Music]